منذ ساعات في شوارع مدينه انطاكيا في
ولايه هاتاي
الحقيقه لا نكاد نمر بزقاق او بشارع دون
ان نرى العشرات من المنازل المدمره الدمار
لم يفطر فقط المنازل بل ايضا المستشفيات
هذا المستشفى الخاص الذي وقع نصفه تقريبا
ولنا ان نتخيل حاله المرضى وحاله المسعفين
الذين عاشوا ربما ساعات من الظهر
هؤلاء الذين استطاعوا منهم الحركه وحول
الخروج لكن كيف لمن كانوا في اسرتهم ولا
يستطيعون الخروج وكيف عاشوا تلك الدقيقه
الواحده بثوانيها الطوال وكيف عاشها يعني
سكان هذه المدينه الصوره ربما ستبقى ويبدو
ان الارقام سوف تكون كبيره هناك من يتحدث
عن عشرات الالاف من القتلى صوت سيارات
الاسعاف لم يتوقف منذ ان وصلنا الى
المدينه قبل ساعات وهذا بالنظر الى وصول
العشرات والعشرات والعشرات من سيارات
الاسعاف من الولايات التركيه الاخرى الى
هذه الولايه ووصول ايضا لمساعدات التي
بدات تتدفق بشكل كبير الى هذه الولايه حول
لانقاذ واسعاف وتقديم المعونه والمساعده
لسكانها الذين يبيتون في شوارعها وساحاتها
لانهم يخافون من العوده الى منازلهم التي
تضررت او ما بقي منها يعني التي تضررت
بشكل كلي او جزئي بنظر الى الصدمه التي
خلفها الزلزال بالاضافه الى استمرار
الهزات الارتداديه بنسبه الجزيره انطاكيا